now the Middle East's longest ruling
monarch Oman Sultan Qaboos bin side
outside has died aged 79 three days of
mourning had been declared and the
process has begun to choose who will
take over computers had no children and
never publicly named a successor he's
credited with modernizing the Gulf
country and mediating between rivals in
a volatile region Rob Matheson looks
back at his life Qaboos bin saeed al
saeed was an only son born in 1942 a
life of royal privilege and to a father
he would overthrow 30 years later what
he did basically is modernizing the
country opening the country to the
outsiders and thirdly looking at the
domestic products and try to move on to
state formation we're building
established institutions and and related
elements Sultan Qaboos was educated in
Oman and then at a private school in the
UK before graduating from Sandhurst
Military Academy and serving in the
British Army for several months on his
return to Amman in 1966 his
determination to modernize his country
is said to have been ignored by his
father four years later backed by the
British Sultan Qaboos seized the throne
he was immediately plunged into his
first crisis an uprising by communists
endure far in the south of a man who
wanted independence it took a further
six years before the fighting ended with
a man being supported by forces from
Britain Jordan and Iran
Aman's links with Iran as well as its
foreign policy of maintaining good
relations with other neighboring
countries have made it one of the main
negotiators in the Gulf a man basically
rely on it is own understanding of
geopolitics being realistic I'll also
maintain it his own legacy of being you
know the oldest State State experience
in the Gulf as a whole that flexible
foreign policy has been controversial in
October 2018 Sultan Qaboos met Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu in the
Omani capital mosque at the meeting
dismayed critics who said Arab states
should not be hosting Israeli leaders
until peace was established between
Israel and the Palestinians Aman's
foreign minister said his country was
simply facilitating efforts towards
negotiations so no caboose had rarely
been seen in public since he went
through lengthy medical treatment in
Germany in 2015 he was unmarried and had
neither children nor siblings and he did
not publicly name a successor the
foreign policy already was I would say
dynamic brag Matic and and and also open
to the idea of engaging with the
international community and that that
true dimension make me eyes make me
believe that we should not expect a
major change now the world waits to see
who will replace a man who modernized
his small Gulf nation and maintained a
delicate balance of loyalties in an
often unstable region well as reaction
is felt throughout the region we have
Mohamed Al Attar band sana that's the
capital of Vermont's neighbor Yemen but
first let's talk to acid bike who's in
Tehran for us acid it does seem that
Iran has always felt they had a friend
in a man under cabooses leadership how
was he being remembered there
well they've had a very close
relationship for a number of years even
historically even before the before Iran
became Islamic Republic of Iran in the
1970s when Oman faced a Marxist
rebellion in the south
Iran then ruled by the Shah dispatched
4000 soldiers 700 Iranian soldiers died
and Amon has never really forgotten that
a man hasn't remained mainly neutral in
the region during the iran-iraq war
between 1980 and 1988 there were secret
talks held between Iran and Iraq in
Muscat now although nothing became of
those it helped reduce the mistrust
between the two countries and Oman
supported a United Nations resolution
asking for a ceasefire and if I could
just list some of the mediation that
Oman has done with Iran or for Iran so
the meet in 1991 they mediated between
Iran and Egypt in 2007 between UK and
Iran in 2008 and 2009 the United States
dispatched a high-level delegation to
Muscat so to discuss nuclear cooperation
with Iran in 2013 there were secret
talks between the United States and Iran
in Oman over Iran's nuclear program
which led to the 2015 nuclear agreement
now we know from former US diplomats
that amant approached the United States
to start those talks to say that there
was a possibility of talks between the
two countries and among very much said
to the United States that try and look
at the region from an Iranian
perspective we've had issues of us
hikers being detained in Iran and Oman
mediated the release of those and also
there were four Iranian Nationals held
in the United States and Oman mediated
the release of those Iranians so they've
had a very close relationship just back
in April last year there was a joint
military naval military exercise in the
Strait of Hormuz and of course the two
countries share that the narrowest point
between the two countries in the Strait
of Hormuz that strategic waterway is
only 33 kilometers so Iran holds a
and the sultan very close to their heart
and Amon has represented Iran in cases
where the embassies have been closed in
such as United Kingdom and Canada a
third bike they're speaking to us from
Tehran thank you acid
well now let's go to Mohammed a lot I've
in Yemen's capital and Mohammed we've
been hearing there about the mediation
efforts that caboose and participated in
in the region he also was very much the
quite diplomat when it came to trying to
end the war in the Yemen
talk us through how he's now regarded in
sana yes the the late Sultan Qaboos bin
Zayed has played a major role in
bringing to the negotiating table the
warring sides including the Houthis and
also the internationally recognized
governments
he has also facilitated in the and some
of the problems that faced Yemenis
especially with the Saudi imposed
blockade and ban on sana International
Airport he facilitated the fly of the
medical flies and also the diplomatic
flights so the Houthis and all other
politicians who want to travel outside
the country used to travel from Sanaa to
oh man
so the the role that has been played
during the last five years by Amana is
is admired by many people here in Yemen
especially that the Omari policy of
friends and also an enemy to none has
also helped a man to thrive economically
and also to have a good relationship
with its neighbors the the cetera being
the current developments in the region
also the continuation of the war between
the saudi-led coalition of the Hafiz we
will have also an impact and the
developments of after the aftermath of
the death of the Sultan especially many
people hope that the Sultan Qaboos his
successor would continue their the march
of Sultana Mabus and also continually
the mediation that has started by the
Sultana and South also the the many also
expected suspects
expect the successor will face a
difficult difficulties especially with
the Saudi Arabia's attempts to pay its
way for the oil pipeline through the
Yemeni territories to the Arab see the
in more than one occasion the late
Sultan Qaboos bin Saeed has faced many
difficulties with Saudi Arabia even
though that he still continued his
policy of as a neutral but such problem
has closed because there many many
challenges that would could have started
a war with thee with Saudi Arabia with
such attempts even though that the
tribes that have been backed by the
Saudi Arabia have failed in order to
give Saudi Arabia domination in an
mahara which is in the borderline with
the oh man Mohamed Al Attar there for us
in Sunna Yemen's capital Thank You
Mohammed well a man's defense council
that's made up of the heads of the Armed
Forces and other security officials has
convened members of the royal family to
choose a successor
they have three days to settle on who
should take ov and if they fail to do
this they'll then turned to Sultan
cabooses choice of successor he wrote
this in two identical field letters
there are two of them in case one of
them gets lost
now that individual will then be
revealed by muskets royal court before
taking the throne well joining us here
in Doha is Margie berry who's director
of the Gulf Study Center at Castile
University Madhu let's start with his
legacy when he took over there were less
than 10 kilometers of paved roads in
Oman and now we're seeing hospitals
we're seeing universities
how was he being remembered today I
think too there are many people he will
be remembered the leader who basically
put together a modern amat and basically
when it comes to the state formation
State Building when it comes to the
institution formation when it comes to
the infrastructure when it comes
including you know health service
education including you know focusing on
a human being and trying to build
the human capacity of a man in the last
50 years I think all our manners would
remember this will remember sort of a
man so thought was because of that but
despite his popularity my job there
there were protests in amman during the
arab spring spring not not hugely large
ones where there were protests and there
has been a crackdown
you know the Arab Spring wave actually
get to a man in mid of 2011 and the
world there was some demonstrations and
Salalah and I think also on Muscat and
almost demonstration were focused on
some requested for more reform actually
and and for more salary increase in all
of this and I think the government also
tackled them using all of their tools to
just to count down the situation and
that which caused at that time criticism
from human rights organizations and has
there been subsequent criticism because
some even though there is protests
weren't necessarily directed at him and
they have been well I guess some some
rewards I changed I think the the
rolling family and including this one
they were clear on that because they
actually dismissed a lot of senior
officials cabinets and and actually
blaming them for not doing their job
properly
and any criticism the criticism from a
human rights organization focused on
some legislation when it comes to the
the right for demonstrate the right the
freedom of speech the freedom for
assembly and all of this and it seems
also the authorities have responded to
that and and they have their own
justification for some of this for some
of those legislations but it's again the
whole the whole development in a man in
the last 10 years approved to to show
that there is serious leadership which
basically managed to avoid you know push
the country out of any bad ramification
on a man well going beyond the borders
we were we were listening to our
correspondents there tell us about how
his mediation efforts
almost made oh man a kind of Switzerland
of the Middle East a kind of neutral
party a space for mediation and we've
obviously seen heightened tensions in
that region
very
recently how is this death likely to
effect thing you know interestingly in
2008 he has an entry deal certain taboos
with one of the Arabic newspaper and he
was asked about you know what Raymond is
doing and he said very simple um we have
no problem with anyone and we don't add
fuel to the fire
and that was how he defined basically
there are many role basically I think
the mediation effort it was two things
helped a man to be mediator when the
legacy of a man a man is the longest
state and in the Gulf it has more than
100 for 40 years that that's a good
experience of statehood the second one
is actually you know the the the style
of leadership of Savannah was himself
and the way how he put how to put
together the state I think that helped
him his experience being you know
graduated from Sandhurst did help him a
lot and actually also you know being an
open country because a man when you
speak about a man a man was open to all
nationalities for more than 100 years
and that basically made the country the
political culture of the country more
open accepting the others and I think
this reflect on politics and foreign
policy and I I think that that helped
the decision makers to behave like this
and not to be worried of a OBO being
mediator and playing role and a lot of
conflicts awesome very very big shoes to
fill their margins weary from cattle
University thank you for joining us
again here on al-jazeera